- [Speaker 1] I want it.
I got it.
I want it.
- I want those, too.
- [Speaker 1] I got it.
I want it.
(taps)
(laughs)
- I love that sound.
- [Speaker 1] I want it.
- I want (gobbles).
(laughing offscreen)
(blues music)
Oh!
Mm!
(grunts)
Why do I love watching
things getting smooshed
in slow motion?
'Specially at the end
when it does that little sploof.
(cups ting)
Oh!
This looks like a Spider-Man thing.
(sharply inhales)
I dunno if that's the optimal way
of taking them off.
I'm not a cupping expert.
Do I think it works?
Hmm.
I'm gonna assume that there is
a decent amount of it
that is a placebo effect.
But there's also probably some benefit
in terms of distracting you from the pain.
Also, increasing circulation to the fascia
and the tissues in that area.
- I have had one hour of sleep,
one brownie,
two shots of espresso,
and I am ready to either fight God,
or die trying.
- I went through all of med school
and residency
without really drinking coffee.
Now, I am addicted.
And I am on the caffeine kick.
By the way,
if haven't seen Bianca
Antisera on the channel,
you need to.
We played Would You Rather.
- This video is for Dr.
Mike, and Dr. Mike only.
So if you're not Dr. Mike, keep scrolling.
Please explain to me
what the actual purpose
of a uvula is other than being
a very fancy, squishy chandelier
for the back of my facial cavity.
- The little boxing bag
that you're referring to
in the back of your throat,
also known as the palatine uvula,
is really put there
in order to prevent
liquids and foods from
entering our nasal cavities.
And it lubricates the throat.
And, one of the most important things,
in case choke it serves
as your gag reflex.
- [Speaker 2] Y'all wanna know
how to get a tan super fast?
Use some Pam organical.
- No!
- [Speaker 2] Original.
This is after 30 minutes.
I'll get back to y'all in an hour.
And this is after an hour and a half.
- No!
Why!?
You are not a chicken in a pot.
Do not use Pam to cook yourself.
In all serious, if you put oil,
you're literally magnifying the rays
that cause skin cancer.
(emotional violin music)
(laughs)
Patients now are bringing in printouts
of what they read online
about their condition
or potential condition.
While a lot of the stuff you
find online is not accurate,
it fosters a good conversation
so you understand how
a doctor's mind works,
so I'm all for it.
As long as you bring it in,
and not just self-treat.
(bright music)
(suspenseful music)
I am literally falling apart.
I had eye surgery,
my teeth are falling apart,
I had some abnormal vein on my face,
I had my shoulder injected
'cause I had AC joint arthropathy,
my low back has been acting up,
I can't stand up without
making sound effects
'cause everything is just achy and sore.
If I have three glasses of alcohol,
all of sudden I can't
function the next day.
(sigh)
Sigh.
- Hi, it's Babs, and
here's a quick health tip.
Tablespoon of apple cider vinegar,
Bragg's,
in a cup of room temperature water,
taken right before bedtime,
help with weight loss,
help with your gut,
unbelievable,
it gives you a good night sleep.
- Dude, she wrote everything
that's troubling society right now:
weight loss, gut health,
digestion, complexion,
so much more.
Imagine I spent 10 years educating myself
on the pathophysiology,
and the pharmacology,
and the anatomy,
when all I had to go was, floop!
And now I just solved all the problems
that are ailing society.
Why don't we just give this
to everybody and end this?
- You're not gonna believe
what just happened.
- Promise, I am.
- I go to get my flu shot.
- Don't do me wrong here.
- And she goes,
"All right, well do you want
it in your left or right arm?"
I said, "My left, but I
have a long sleeve shirt on,
so I don't know if it's
gonna pull up all the way.
I might just have to take
my arm out, if that's okay."
And before I could even do that,
she doesn't even answer me.
Really.
She doesn't give me an option.
She goes, "Oh, that's okay.
This happens all the time.
No issues."
Bop!
Through, she gives me the
shot through my shirt.
So now do I have a piece of cotton
in my bloodstream just floating around?
- No, this is not normal
and you shouldn't be doing this.
One, you have to look at
where you're injecting.
You have to see a clean surface.
You have to clean it
with a alcohol wipe in
order to disinfect the area.
Also, you wanna make
sure you're not injecting
into a mole or already infected source.
Imagine underneath the shirt,
she had a big cellulitis and
infection there, an abscess,
and now you're injecting into it.
You gotta visualize where
you're injecting, number one.
Number two, to answer your question,
you don't just have cotton floating around
in your body or whatever material
because likely the needle
penetrated the holes
of the fibers and didn't
cut through the fiber.
And, even if it did,
it wouldn't just be floating in your body.
It would just be in that area,
and then your body would
naturally push it out.
While I don't think that's
the biggest problem.
I do think that's an irresponsible
way to give a flu shot.
If that really happened,
I would probably complain about it
'cause that's not the norm.
- There are 20 case
reports in the literature
of people whose colons
have either exploded
or caught fire during surgery.
The colon makes methane
and some hydrogen gas
and if that combines with
oxygen and a source of energy,
like a Bovie or a laser, that can ignite.
- A Bovie is the electrocautery tool
that we sometimes use instead
of a scalpel to cut tissue.
Benefits of that is it actually
cuts and cauterizes at the same time,
so it minimizes bleeding.
- There's been a case where
the surgeon caught fire
and another couple cases
where the colon exploded
and the patient died.
- Logically, it all makes
sense and it could happen.
I'll just put it this way.
When I counsel my patients,
when they're going
for pre-op screening
and I counsel them on the
procedure they're gonna get,
I don't usually include
exploding colon as part of the risks.
(explosion)
- How can your body replicate the feeling
of falling from high
altitude in a nightmare,
if you've never fallen like that.
- This is actually a really
good and interesting question.
So psychologists believe
that the fear of falling
is actually an evolutionary
or innate trait within us
to actually protect us.
So it's different from
the fear of heights,
which some people have,
but almost every human
and almost every animal
has the fear of falling.
They've even tested this in infants
as young as like six months old.
If they put them near a glass floor
that's a few feet up
and then their mothers call them
the infants will actually
avoid the glass floor
or not come at all
because, even at that age,
without the experience of falling,
they innately know that
it's a dangerous thing.
- ASAP Science comes through
again with some accurate info!
(claps)
Well done!
Something I can add to this conversation,
because I work in a neonatology ward
as a family medicine doctor,
one of the reflexes we test in babies
is called the moro reflex.
It's kind of evil when you see us do it,
when we essentially
rapidly dropped the baby.
You're not actually making contact,
the baby's not falling,
but you basically lower
the baby really quickly.
The baby kind of tries to
grasp on and save itself
because it has the
innate survival mechanism
known as the moro reflex.
So this is something we
are innately born with.
Another species, this is very evident,
is puppies.
A newborn puppy, you put 'im near stair,
they know not to go down the stairs.
They don't just throw themselves down
even though no one walked up to them
and was like,
"Hey, these are stairs,
if you go down gravity'll go (spirts)."
Click here for me and a mortician
partnering up watching Six Feet Under
or check me out another day in the life
in my hospital on a COVID
ward or unit or wing
whichever you like.
As always stay happy and healthy.
Click!
(upbeat dance music fades in)